well you hear about the devastation each
and every year from wildfires in many
western states in Nevada just as
vulnerable as our neighbors so this
Saturday marks 10 years
of ours spread through part of the
spring mountains the news now weather
reporter Mary Jane valiazza takes us to
Mount Charleston with the restoration
efforts in place
it was very difficult to get to so it
was burning for a couple of days and
then it crested on the Hills behind us
Ray Johnson a fire prevention officer
with the U.S forest Service remembers
July 1st 2013 like it was yesterday and
that's when the thoughts and talk
talking about the evacuations started to
take place you can see how close the
fire came to threatening homes here in
the old town subdivision of Kyle Canyon
residents could see the fire right from
their backyard with some people having
to evacuate for more than two weeks it
threatened the rainbow and Old Town
communities I suppose Echo as well it
was very traumatic up here unfortunately
we lost a lot of trees some of them were
thousands of years old now new growth of
vegetation is slowly taking over the
charred remnants thankfully fuel
reduction treatments from the past years
mitigated the intensity of the blaze
helping firefighters keep the Flames at
Bay however it wasn't just the fire
residents had to worry about shortly
after we had some tropical depressions
that came up the Baja Peninsula and came
straight to here with a ton of rain and
we had some catastrophic flooding
Joshua thaleker a fuel specialist for
the U.S
it was a team effort to work with Clark
County and the Army Corps of Engineers
to create this channel to prevent the
flooding and let the vegetation grow
back they built a diversion Channel
around the community to divert all the
flood waters Johnson wants to remind
everyone to stay safe and aware this
time of year we've had a wet winter that
doesn't mean that we're not going to
have fires